et pour revenir sur le l'iran nous
sommes en direct avec thierry coville
chercheur à l'iris et spécialiste de
l'iran bonjour monsieur coville merci
d'avoir pris le temps d'accepter notre
invitation alors l'iran est aujourd'hui
confronté à une triple triple
catastrophe le koala virus les sanctions
américaines et la chute du pétrole
on va essayer d'en parler ce d'essayer
de trous de vous poser des questions sur
chaque point alors tout d'abord
concernant les sanctions mac pompéo
réclament le maintien de l'embargo sur
les ventes d'armes à l'iran au delà du
mois d'octobre
pourtant c'était la date qui était prévu
par le par l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien
comment comprenez vous cette requête de
washington c'est un c'est cohérent avec
leur politique de pression maximum sur
l'iran tout ce qui peut pénaliser l'iran
est bon pour les etats-unis
alors cela ou effectivement ça pose
problème c'est que ça faisait partie de
la course au nucléaire de 2015
et dans cet accord effectivement partir
d'octobre 2020 l'embargo sur les armes
considérant devaient être supprimés
alors là il reste à savoir est ce qu'on
considère c'est comme des états unis qui
ont quitté cet accord donc que c'est un
peu bizarre d'un cookie qui s'opposent
au bon déroulement de cet accord aussi
l'oreille tout débat à savoir est-ce que
l'iran l'a vraiment respectée on sait
qu'ils ont pris des mesures pour en
sortir mais je répète le gros problème
c'est les états unis qui sont sortis en
mai 2018 qu'ils reconnaissent eux mêmes
qui n'ont pas respecté cet accord donc
c'est un petit peu étonnant qui est ce
utile cet accord qu'ils n'ont pas
respectées pour dire voilà l'iran n'a
pas respecté sa part mais ça revient ce
politique de pression maximum des états
unis pression maximum également après le
lancement d'un premier satellite
militaire mercredi puisque washington le
vit comme une provocation et appelle
l'union européenne a sanctionné les
individus et les entités qui collaborent
à ce programme quelle peut être la
réaction des européens alors les
européens ont déjà réagi en me disant
que les teams ans il était inquiet de
2,7 dans le sens de ce satellite ont
cédé inquiétudes qu'ont déjà été émise
par rapport au programme balistique
iranien il faut rappeler que de nouveaux
on revient cet accord nucléaire par la
résolution
il ya cet accord se déclare 2015 qui
interdit à l'iran de procéder à des
essais balistiques
si les missiles peuvent porter des
charges nucléaires hors liesse que
guérande ils ont fait des essais des
essais de lancement de satellites
rien n'est prouvé rien ne prouve que
c'est va permettra d'envoyer des charges
nucléaires si vous n'êtes mais de
nouveau je reviens c'est quand même
assez étonnant on dit dans un monde a
quand même étonnant où les etats-unis
disent que l'iran doit respecter brands
international est donc cette résolution
des nations unies alors que eux mêmes
l'ont quittée donc là je pense que à
l'occasion de cette crise on en parle
quel monde on veut le dr s'il ya des
règles à droit international il même
pour tout le monde dont les états unis
peuvent pas sortir de cet accord étaient
ensuite l'iran doit respecter là il ya
quelque chose qui a pas et benoît on
revient dans la position européenne les
européens effectivement ils ont des
inquiétudes soins balistique iranien
mais fois peut-être que il s'engage un
peu plus pour défendre le droit
international et qui rappelle aux états
unis que c'est quand même eux ont créé
des problèmes en sortant de cet accord
on le disait le corona virus continue de
circuler en iran et je voudrais que vous
réagissiez sur ses déclarations de la
trace a d'abord parmi les robes doit
envisager le scénario le plus pessimiste
selon lesquelles les conséquences etc et
économiques de l'épidémie se feront
sentir pendant des mois ou voir pendant
dépendent en un an selon le président
iranien est ce que c'est un aveu sur la
situation dramatique que traverse le
pays selon vous un très clairement
d'après le fmi est de nouveau en grande
partie à cause des sanctions américaines
l'iran a enregistré une récession de -9
5% en 2019 et une inflation qui est près
de 40% alors vous imaginez dans ce
contexte l'activité économique s'est
arrêtée quasiment pendant à peu près un
mois en iran donc la grande peur des
autorités iraniennes et c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont demandé un l'activité de
repartir et que
l'économie s'effondre encore plus et ça
conduit à des troubles sociaux comme ils
ont déjà enregistré en novembre 2010
marque donc à une véritable inquiétude
de ce côté là concernant le nombre de
contaminés en iran on ne connaît pas le
chiffre réel
elle serait de dix fois plus que les
statistiques officielles est ce que vous
confirmez
tout est faux je pense qu'il faut rester
prudent le problème et clients c est
plus une politisation des chiffres et
est-ce qu'il faut dire si tu as des
inquiétudes même en iran il ya un grand
quotidien iranien qui aujourd'hui disait
voilà on a du mal à croire ces chiffres
que nous donnent les autorités
iraniennes à ce que tous les cas un
débat il faut bien comprendre en iran
d'un côté et effectivement il ya cette
crise mais il ya également les
inquiétudes sur le fait que les gens
sont obligés de rester chez eux n'ont
plus d'activité économique et l'iran en
grande partie à cause des centres
américaine n'a pas les moyens comme on
fait en france de compenser telle est
gentil on travaille plus c'est pour ça
que les autorités iraniennes sont un peu
coincé elles sont obligés de dire aux
gens au pouvoir commencer à travailler
mais effectivement il dénonce
inquiétudes en iran même un peu cher
contrairement à ce qu'on dit un débat en
iran sur est ce que c'est bien coude
encombre commence à travailler dans les
stations-service écoutèrent à la radio à
la bbc ce matin du jean genet n'ya pas
les deux gants ya pas de minces les gens
disent on doit jeter des masses mais ce
que le gouvernement va compenser pas
financièrement
donc il ya des vraies inquiétudes qu'on
entend en iran même et je pense qu'en
compagnie on en revient à cette histoire
le gouvernement iranien n'a pas les
moyens de comme en france dire de ces
pardons financer le chômage partiel il
est obligé de dire aux gens vont
commencer à travailler effectivement
aider leurs inquiétudes par rapport aux
conséquences sur sur le développement
d'épidémies
est-ce que dernière question vous
et dire que l'iran n'avait pas les
moyens de faire face à cette crise est
ce que des pays comme la russie pourrait
lui venir en aide
je pense que là effectivement si on
n'arrête pas de nous dire que le ccri
devrait nous faire conscience que le
monde doit changer
quand on est une crise de cette ampleur
je pense que la moindre des choses on
est tous dans le même bateau
donc les rangs par exemple on vous en
avait parlé dans votre part demandé un
prêt au fmi d'iran et membre du fmi'
pourquoi le fmi n'est de re et allianz
mais pourquoi un seul pays les états
unis dit aurait le droit national
effectivement et l'europe
mon avis devrait arrêter de se cacher et
de d'avoir peur des sanctions
américaines je pense le moment est grave
pour tout le monde parce que si la crise
se développe en iran tous les autres
pays peuvent être touchées effectivement
l'europe devrait d un peu plus les rangs
un peu commence à faire la russie aussi
lâché je crois a commencé et délirant
mais je pense que ça c'est une costume
qui dépasse les simples vos alliés de
l'iran ça concerne on va dire l'ensemble
de l'environnement international qui
devrait se poursuivre va permettre pour
aider les rangs parce que ses cris de
quotas que l'iran mais mais on voit bien
ça concerne la région et l'ensemble de
la planète
merci beaucoup thierry coville d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur à l'iris et
spécialiste de l'iran